[Música]
olá boa tarde gente começou muito
obrigada
é ela queria começar perguntando pra
vocês porque que o sucesso da gestão
feminina ainda é tratado como um
fenômeno porque quando a gente tem uma
mulher no lugar de protagonismo de
gestão
ela ainda é tratada como extraordinária
e porque quando essa mulher ocupa esse
lugar seja na sua própria empresa
é no seu no seu negócio ela empreendeu o
número de uma empresa da qual ela é
funcionária ela geralmente a única única
não faz voz porque isso ainda acontece
mesmo depois de tanto a gente falar e
batalhar pelo empoderamento feminino
bom eu queria dizer pra vocês que além
de atriz e autora
vocês já devem ter visto alguma coisa
que eu fiz ao longo dos meus 25 anos de
carreira é eu também sua gestora da
minha própria caminhada
dona das minhas escolhas e também
recentemente me tornei empreendedora
social como isso aconteceu eu tive um
convite de uma grande revista feminina
para escrever uma coluna à qual deu o
nome de dona de si porque porque eu
queria dividir com as leitoras se eu
tivesse é todas as minhas dores como
empreendedora de mim mesma
estava aqui instalado engasgado e eu
comecei a escrever sobre tudo isso que
estou falando para vocês protagonismos e
é a única sempre como escritor é a única
das equipes
e aí pra minha surpresa eu tava sendo
lida e eu estava sendo lida por muita
gente e eu voltava meu e-mail e
começaram a se comunicar comigo e
começaram a contar pra mim também das
suas dores que eram os mesmos
bom a grande dor feminina no mundo do
empreendedorismo é a quebra do fluxo de
negócios
sabe por que eu fui atrás das
estatísticas a então ficou mais a taxa
de empreendedorismo inicial das mulheres
no brasil hoje é de 53% e dos homens 49
por cento então nós temos muita coragem
para começar essa estatística é um
grande espelho
agora quando eu fui atrás de si espelho
dos números eu descobrir que na taxa de
empreendedorismo estabelecido que são as
empresas que têm maior mais de três anos
de funcionamento
58 por cento são homens os gestores e 42
por cento são mulheres e isso realmente
bateu com tudo que estava recebendo 2
mil leitoras com a estatística
comecei a pesquisar as causas disso
acontecer com as minhas leitoras também
a primeira causa conhecimento não já que
27% das mulheres 27% de toda a formação
superior no brasil é de homens e 34% é
de mulheres lucratividade também não
porque negócios com gestão feminina
estavam lucrando de 5 20% a mais segundo
a oit
bom então tinha alguma razão que eu não
encontrava nas pesquisas mas que eu
queria encontrar no tete a tete com as
minhas leitoras e foi isso que aconteceu
a razão maior precisa essa quebra de
fluxo de negócios femininos não é a
falta de apoio familiar é a falta de
apoio do mercado
adoro o que acontece
nós já não estamos inseridas na
sociedade empoderadas o que acontece com
essa falta de apoio como ela se revela
bom
primeiro o pressão diária opressão é um
olhar opressão é o abraço sempre aquele
abraço que passa a mão nas nossas costas
assim isso é uma pressão e isso vem da
cultura machista o cara que tá fazendo
as vezes ele nem tá ligado nisso
abraço que pega bem na cintura da mulher
que está indo pra fechar um negócio você
já começa a reunião acabada
você demora dez minutos só pra se
reconectar com seu poder não é assim
bom a falta de financiamento do viés
inconsciente misógino que é quando
duvidam da capacidade da entrega de uma
mulher e isso inconsciente
eu não estou aqui apontando o dedo para
os homens eu tô aqui colocando uma
questão cultural que a gente precisa
ficar atento bom que isso acaba gerando
nas mulheres e e isso gera descrença em
si mesma
isso gera esgotamento das suas forças
porque a gente só lida com as nossas
forças e acaba quebrando gera também uma
falta de conforto no lugar do sucesso
uma submissão mesmo quando a gente a
chef às vezes a gente tem que se tomar
de uma ou outra personalidade para poder
ser ouvida e uma falta de referência
feminina em lugares de poder que como eu
comecei nós somos sempre únicas
extraordinárias fenomenais
não é normal a mulher nesse lugar
bom essa conseqüência é terrível e ela
na verdade vem mostrar pra gente que tá
acontecendo um problema grave dentro do
empoderamento feminino e que nós
mulheres precisamos resolver e para
resolver a gente precisa estar
consciente ele o problema é a nossa
sobrecarga
o problema da falta de apoio é que a
gente precisa fazer tudo
o problema disso é a síndrome do eu
aguento é que ser guerreira virou elogio
e não é guerreira faz a gente cansada
nossa própria força e nós estamos
quebrando e isso está gerando uma
solidão nas gestoras femininas no brasil
como é que eu poderia comunicar esse
protagonismo instável para as minhas
leitoras como comer como eu conseguiria
abordar esse assunto sem se crítica com
mulheres formadas sem ser arrogante com
mulheres que estão batalhando
diariamente assim como eu então dentro
da minha pesquisa eu juntei uma pesquisa
com as minhas leitoras magra
do sebrae ea minha expertise com
dramaturgia e construir cinco
personagens femininas gestoras que mais
aparecem pra gente como sofrendo da
sobrecarga
a primeira delas é a gestora cansada
a gestora cansada realmente ela esquece
de si é que vocês estão vendo baixo
nessa tua mão você está regular
a grande força da já estava cansada que
é muito responsável então coitada ela
disse sim para as coisas para os outros
disse não pra ela mesma claro e ela
nunca controla o seu tempo e o que
comecei a desenvolver para as minhas
leitoras como é que a gente pode ser
deixar de ser uma gestora cansada
exausta e ser uma gestora dona de si o
que é ser dona de si uma dona de si não
carrega o mundo nas costas uma dona de
cita inteira nela mesma
uma dona de si é tão generosa com ela
mesma que ela tem consciência exata das
suas forças das suas fraquezas
ela caminha comprometida com seu
propósito e alinhada com o seu sonho de
menina ela não esquece de quem ela é
então aplicando a gestora dona de ensino
a gestora cansada ela se torna uma
gestora dona do seu tempo
a gestora competitiva por exemplo que
foi outra também apareceu demais foi
muito bom materiais 100 mulheres
a fragilidade aquela se compara o tempo
inteiro com a outra colega que está do
lado sabe aquela que tem ímpeto de
correr mas ela está sempre olhando pro
lado ela acaba dando com a cara na
parede é isso que acontece
ela tem uma força imensa que a coragem
ela vai
mas o que acaba acontecendo ela começa
tem várias inimigos porque é muito
competitiva e isso isso é um problema
histórico que a gente precisa quebrar
porque a gente não tá mas no baile
competindo pelo príncipe
a gente está fazendo negócio a gente
está fazendo dinheiro
essa mulher quando proativa na vila uma
gestora inclusiva que trabalha com
aquela colega que poderia ser sua grande
inimiga ou às vezes ela transforma uma
inimiga numa
grande parceira sim porque a gestora
competitiva depois que ela vira durante
se ela não precisa mais ter a minha
amigas
a gente já tem a gestora recente ida
muito talentosa mas ela precisa de
reconhecimento é sua grande fragilidade
qual é a sua grande força o seu talento
ela é muito talentosa no que ela faz e
quando ela entende a sua força ea sua
fraqueza e o cenário que eu estou
colocando aqui pra vocês
ela passa a ser uma gestora consciente
do seu impacto no mundo e aí ninguém
mais segura essa mulher
a gestora invisível essa maravilhosa
essa geralmente aquela nossa colega que
ficasse no fundo da sala atrás do
computador mas ela sabe todo mundo a
hora que todo mundo toma um remédio ela
sabe tem várias não é bom a grande
fragilidade dessa gestora é o medo da
rejeição por isso assim toca num lugar
da sala para que ninguém veja
e com essa grande força é a maravilhosa
do planejamento você pode confiar nela
totalmente
eu ando começa pelos reconhecimentos bom
que acontece com essa gestora quando ela
se assume dona de si dona da sua
fragilidade porque não adianta mais a
gente já é dona da nossa força mas a
gente tá quebrando com ela
não é só a força de vontade que vai
fazer a gente
dona de si é boa vontade do mercado e
para isso a gente precisa conhecer a
nossa fragilidade
essa mulher quando dona de si ela é
absolutamente inclusiva na sua equipe
ela pode até continuar com a mesma linha
dela mas ela vai ter uma mesa no meio
redonda a reunião né
maravilhosa é isso que eu começo a ouvir
sempre é muito bom obrigada
bom depois da gestora invisível vem a
gente estou ansiosa olá tudo bem e estou
ansiosa é a grande fragilidade é ela não
diz não pra nada a pessoa do sim para
tudo menos para ela
e qual é a grande força é muito correta
então ela fica que nem uma louca pra
entregar tudo que ela prometeu e ela não
consegue e ela fica doente
mulher a gente sempre tem alguma coisa
ela sempre quebrou o pé tá com uma
botinha mas ela faz coisas que ninguém
faz contra o botinha enfim quando essa
mulher se não é total
ganhou também gata é quando essa mulher
resolve que ela vai entender essa
fragilidade fala assim não pára aí eu
preciso dizer sim pra mim ela se torna
uma mulher que consegue fazer as coisas
na agilidade no seu tempo
tudo tem um momento certo bom que
acontece quando é uma piada tudo isso é
claro que ninguém passa por isso assim e
fica normal depois né
é eu falei meu deus do céu eu estou
diante de uma coisa que eu nem sabia só
eu só queria escrever uma coluna mas me
veio um sentido de eu preciso fazer
alguma coisa eu preciso deixar de
acreditar
só que a minha vida vai ser pautada e
gerada pelo meu brilho eu preciso que
outras mulheres brin
então por isso um dia eu acordei de
madrugada e teve a idéia do instituto é
dona de si e eu tinha uma coleção de
bolsas de marca que era com que uma
mulher ansiosa consegue comprar rápido
esse indivíduo óbvio bom mas eu vendia
essas bolsas e eu tive um primeiro
investimento já que o sonho era meu
deixar de investir na profissão em
primeiro de fazer o instituto dona
decide montar o que o que que eu
precisava montar o que faltava para as
mulheres gestoras ao meu redor e minhas
leitoras acolhimento escuta ativa
reparte dores só isso aqui é um eu
falando aqui outra falando ali outra que
conta um caso aqui a gente já sai mais
forte
a fragilidade com o escoamento um auto
conhecimento real do que acontece com as
mulheres porque a solidão faz a gente
acha que o problema só nosso
bom isso gerou impacto não só na minha
vida mas na vida de milhares de mulheres
de quebra do teto de cristal sim de
aceleração de talentos porque eu falo
aceleração
capacitação porque a gente já estuda
demais hoje eu queria dizer pra vocês
que o projeto dona de si como um todo já
impactou mais de 500 mil mulheres ea
gente está no nosso terceiro ano ou seja
vamos que vamos né
é eu queria dizer pra vocês que quando
uma mulher age como gestora dona de si
ela interrompe ciclos de crenças ou
professoras quando uma mulher age como
gestora dona de si
ela está consciente das suas
fragilidades e das suas forças
quando uma mulher age como gestora dona
de si
ela sabe que ela jamais estará sozinha
estamos juntas
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]